okay an adventure like that
way to Alaska don't never been to Alaska
but I hear the Northern Lights
absolutely breathtaking
and then I don't know I would just see
where they took me I just I'd be free
hmm
you know it's a shame by the time we
finally figure out what we really want
most the time it's too late not the
Chinese lost outside of a battle you're
right come up with that girl
[Music]
you
what if you could go back in time and
change something you can change anything
you want what would it be dust yourself
up and move on to the next one I don't
want the next one and why do you even
care about look at you you're a tall
girl looking - you could probably have
any girl in this bar you know maybe I
fail to properly explain to you the boss
employee relationship
I tell you what to do and you do it you
help rich people get richer it's like
teaching fish up swim you are really
smart you'd be doing something more with
life you know it's not too late to do
something great
Martha scuzz are really coming to you I
don't know what I'm doing help me help
me you're eating too much cheese okay
one winner the old-fashioned way with
your words or you kill her boyfriend
called you crazy I need you apologize
because I should have told you that I
had a boyfriend I don't want to look
back on this moment and think why didn't
I go after it I don't regret time travel
it is in fact something that may become
a reality but in you continue your
research and can only handle so much
failure you to send me back in time to a
point before she meets this guy she's
but now she thinks she's
[Music]
I can't send you back look these
equations they're still unsolved so
unless you could solve them that you
know what let's just give up I actually
envy you you gave me the guy that I got
it's in love with a girl he can't have I
am me the guy who knows what he wants
and is afraid to go after it this this
lifelong quest that I was on was
actually about something else altogether
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
and of course me with you
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
you